et qui dit emplois dit écoles
aujourd'hui face aux inégalités d'accès
beaucoup d'universités ou de grandes
écoles sont tenter d'aménager leur
concours pour réserver des places aux
élèves des quartiers défavorisés
c'est ce qu'on appelle parfois la
discrimination positive un établissement
prestigieux le fait depuis plusieurs
années
sciences po avec des résultats très
encourageants enquête signée estelle
colin chloé le compte ce n'est pas six
ans pau mais ça y ressemble un jury qui
n'est pas là pour rigoler un candidat
venu pour s'essayer bienvenue a bondi de
l'autre côté du périph on appelle ça un
oral blanc mélangeant tels que la chine
ou l'homme qui conclut une population
très consistante à droite un chef
d'entreprise à gauche
le prof d'économie l'un comme l'autre
aurait pu rester à la maison mais non
chaque semaine dans ce lycée dr ils
consacrent leurs mercredis après-midi à
ces jeunes dont il apprécie avant tout
l'appétit de réussite fait évidemment
des gens qui sont plus intéressants que
sont les jantes en plus fins sont des
gens qui sont plus demandeurs ces gens
qui ont en plus envie de montrer qu'ils
vont réussir
les voilà ces jeunes leur père et
chômeurs ouvriers ou employés et leurs
profs ont décidé de les coacher objectif
rentrer à sciences po par la porte
réservée aux plus défavorisés
on appelle ça une convention d'éducation
prioritaire un système dont les profs de
bondy furent jadis les pionniers c'était
il ya cinq ans il ya un effet de
synergie
tout le monde se dit c'est possible
l'autocensure qu'avait nos élèves est en
train de disparaître l'autocensure
qu'avaient mes collègues aussi une
confiance qui bénéficie à tout le monde
à commencer par ingrid et antoine ils
ont intégré sciences po et prennent
aujourd'hui plaisir à transmettre cette
confiance à ceux qui voudraient les
imiter
et sociales bonnes habitudes pommereuil
ici à sciences po où l'on a parfois
dénoncer les intrus exemple de réactions
parmi les plus révoltantes et les
graffitis dans les toilettes de chance
bon je pensais pas la courneuve où
chaque point sépare vérité se trouve
être du racisme social jure et puis j'ai
beaucoup reçu de l'aide à soultz sur le
thème je fais entre les arabes à sion se
pose qui racisme du convoi fou retour a
bondi pour avoir intégré sciences po
ingrid et samia n'en n'oublie pas pour
autant leur prof qui leur ont appris les
100 sièges pouvoir c'est d'abord vouloir
seul
moi je me suis dis donc au tout début
c'est vrai c'est pas fait pour moi je
suis on se pose c'est inaccessible et
ensuite en fait c'est durant l'été de ma
première que ça s'est vraiment mis en
place et que je me suis dit pourquoi pas
et quand on est volé sec toujours
possible en première année elle vous
coupe non non j'ai falloir de rater le
rendez compte ce qu'ils ont fait pour
moi c'est j'arrête cette alerte
en fait le truc révolutionnaire de de
sciences po ce qui donnait vraiment
envie pour nous de participer à cette
aventure c'est qu'ils arrivent en disant
nous venons recruter des talents tels
qu'ils sont rita lau qui sont là quelque
part et qui jamais ne déçoivent
selon sciences po ces étudiants venus de
quartiers et de milieux difficiles
réussissent aussi bien que les autres